[MUSIC PLAYING]
LEZHIE LI: Hi, everyone.
My name's Lezhi, and I'm a
software engineer at Uber.
So today I'm going to talk about
how we build a visual debugging
tool for machine learning
using TensorFlow.js.
So why is model
debugging important?
Machine learning
practitioners report
that they spend the
majority of their time
not on building a
model, but instead,
on iterating and debugging
of the existing model.
So there's huge
opportunity for us
to improve efficiency
of the 80% of the time.
Traditionally, the only
guidance for model developers
to evaluate a model
performance is
by looking at
performance metrics.
Although these
metrics are useful,
they do not give
too much insight
into how to improve on a
model or why a model performs
in a certain way.
So given the intrinsic opacity
of machine learning algorithms,
it is very hard for
anyone who wants
to try to understand
model performance.
So how do we solve that problem.
The idea here is that we can
transform a model space problem
into a data space problem.
And by that we
mean that, instead
of asking what went
wrong with the model,
we look at on which data did
this model make mistakes.
And instead of asking why a
model makes certain mistakes,
we look into the
future characteristics
of these failed data points.
So based on those two
ideas, we developed
Manifold, which is a model
agnostic visual debugger
for machine learning.
Here's the workflow
of using Manifold.
The user will connect
Manifold to the output data
set of several machine
learning outcomes,
and Manifold will automatically
segment these data sets
into subsets, each
subsets containing
data points with similar
performance with each other.
The users would choose the
subset of their interest
to compare against each
other, and Manifold
would highlight the feature
distribution difference
of these two different
subsets, and helping
them to diagnose the behavior
of the performance outcome.
So while we developed these
ideas into production,
we faced several
technology challenges.
And among them there's a
performance challenge and also
portability challenge.
So traditionally, it is the
model training backend's job
to handle the performance
metric calculation.
But that pattern is
no more applicable
to our visual interface because
of the latency introduced
by the recalculation in response
to the user interaction.
And also, if you want
to connect Manifold
to another machine
learning training back end,
there are two pieces of code we
need to port out, the back end
code and a front end code.
But in reality, the metrics
calculation logic actually
belong to the visual
tool and should not
be injected into the
training back end.
Those two reasons shows why
we put this computation logic
inside of front end.
And because this computation
could get intensive as a data
volume increases,
that's why we use
TensorFlow.js to help us
increase the competition
efficiency.
So what are the
intensive computation
involved in this
Manifold interface?
In performance
configuration view,
we compute and perform
scores for each data point
on each model and
use those metrics
to run the K-means
clustering to segment
this data set into subsets.
And in the future attribution
view, for each feature
we compute the distribution
histograms of the two
different subsets,
and using those
histograms to compute
KL-divergence to rank
that feature importance
for model developers
to inspect the
model performance.
And in all of those
scenarios, TensorFlow.js
gave us a lot of
performance boosting
compared to plain
JavaScript implementation.
And in some cases, the
performance boosting
can be as high as 100 times, for
the per instance model metrics
computation.
So to conclude, complex tasks
such as machine learning
diagnosis can benefit a lot from
numerical computation capacity
of TensorFlow.js.
And TensorFlow.js opens up new
opportunities for developers
of visual analytics source.
OK, that's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]